there is a bunch of brave people this
started in Lebanon and they are doing
something called the burn Isis flag
challenge it even has a hashtag on
Twitter and let's take a look at some
video
okay so as I said this started in
Lebanon but it's it's spreading so to
speak across the Middle East as you can
see some of the people do show their
faces some don't these people have some
ball like whether you're showing your
face or not knowing that everything can
be tracked and traced and tagged and all
that we got to give these people some
credit for having balls right it's
definitely risky but it's interesting to
see some of them using blow torches the
blow to they're not messing around that
seems to be the reaction from YouTube
behind the camera here yeah I have made
the pun and then I kind of stop thank
you for yeah but really we do have to
give these people like these people live
in a part of the world where there is so
little freedom we know what Isis is
doing I mean this was originally a
reaction to them beheading a Lebanese
soldier so we kind of should be backing
these people better trying to fight the
power right I think it was a group of
students that initially did this and
there's video I think on YouTube with
over a hundred thousand views and at the
end of it they challenged the whole
world icebucketchallenge style to also
burn flags yeah so everyone out there
watching don't buy a flag though print
it out don't support them right you can
burn a print out copy do you guys think
in a weird way that when people do these
kinds of things that it somehow
strengthens them you know yeah that's
that's my concern in this is that you
know Isis and and these Islamic
extremists and whatnot are doing a have
a huge outreach campaign on social media
to recruit new people and and my concern
in this is that it's drawing even more
social network attention where it's it
could potentially be the those people
that are on the fence of joining or not
or looking more into the other side of
things
that's just my fear in this that it's
just bringing more media where that's
actually been one of their largest
outlets and recruiting new members yeah
so we've been talking about that because
we've been doing this for weeks we were
doing Isis before it was cool we were
doing it here really back in May I mean
we were talking about this but how much
of that do you think is true like should
we be talking about this because is it
all you know people they were suspending
Twitter accounts that were posting the
beheading video
and they don't want you know they're
taking them off YouTube and all that
because they think it's propaganda to me
I think we kind of have to talk about it
because we need to know what's going on
especially if we're about to enter a
freaking war that doesn't see I don't
want but but but have yeah but how much
do we have to actually talk about it
without strength in the room I think
it's impossible to have one without the
other
yeah you know so you got to have to
weigh it and see what you think is more
beneficial in this case like she said
most of their recruitment is coming from
social media so it is a scary idea but
how else are you gonna get the word out
there how else are you gonna try to make
change statement and in in reading about
this I actually stumbled across
something else that I thought was really
moving which was the rubble challenge
have you have you heard about that it's
a small group of people and Gaza instead
of doing the ice bucket challenge they
actually control where they you know
obviously don't have access to water or
and a lot of them don't have access to
electricity to make ice so they actually
took what something that they do have
access to a tremendous mana which is
rubble yeah import it over their heads
so that statement so it I mean this this
concept is catching on it and it does
make people have discussions like we are
right now so I think that you know and
that sense it's good yeah although at
some of the more of these that we do are
we just watering down all of them no pun
intended there was a bad pun really why
are are we really I mean you know
everyone's doing this now we have we
have secretaries of state that do hash
tag things on Twitter like how much
actual change is any of this affecting
really beyond just kind of making yeah
the information is good it gets us
talking about of that kind of stuff do
you think it really causes any change I
do and I think honestly the more people
talking about it the better I don't
think there's any watering down effect I
think that you know the conversation is
good to have and if people weren't
talking about it before and they aren't
out that's only positive right yes yeah
well then let's end on an agreement